facebook ceo mark zuckerberg is strongly
defending the company he co-founded
after stunning allegations from a former
employee in congressional testimony
whistleblower francis haugen said
facebook chooses profit over public
safety she shared thousands of internal
documents and also spoke with 60 minutes
now zuckerberg is publicly denying
claims the platform is designed to
reward anger and division nicole killian
is on capitol hill for us nicole good
morning to you there's a long note from
mark last night what else is he saying
yeah that's right tony and facebook ceo
mark zuckerberg says the accusations
against his company are not true and
don't make sense and while he disputes
the whistleblowers accusations he says
that he does agree congress should
update internet regulations
almost no one outside of facebook knows
what happens inside of facebook in her
first congressional testimony since
blowing the whistle on facebook
ex-employee frances haugen detailed what
she described was a culture of secrecy
and complacency that put profits over
safety facebook's products harm children
stoke division and weaken our democracy
and she pinned the blame squarely on her
former boss mark zuckerberg in the end
the buck stops with mark there's no one
currently holding mark accountable but
himself the buck stops with him
the buck stops with him haugen called
the social media giant morally bankrupt
she compared them to big tobacco and
said the company's own research shows
its instagram platform can be harmful
and addictive to teens the way that they
pick the content in instagram for young
users for all users
amplifies preferences so facebook knows
that
they are leading young users to anorexia
content documents obtained by cbs news
from a congressional source show the
company conducted a study on teen girls
body image on instagram it found users
experience of downward spiral is
exacerbated by our platform and aspects
of instagram exacerbate each other to
create a perfect storm facebook's own
research says
it is not just that instagram is
dangerous for teenagers that it harms
teenagers
it's that it is distinctly worse than
other forms of social media that on tick
tock it is about funny things
snapchat is about faces but instagram is
about bodies and about social comparison
after the testimony in a lengthy
facebook post zuckerberg wrote the
argument that we deliberately push
content that makes people angry for
profit is deeply illogical and i don't
know any tech company that sets out to
build products that make people angry or
depressed the more time i spend on
instagram the more
sad and depressed i feel jada bromberg
joined instagram at 13 and says she has
struggled with mental health challenges
i've made social media positive for
myself by trying to figure out
what is and isn't helpful to me
zuckerberg who is a father of two says
he's been reflecting about the
experiences he wants his own kids and
other children to have online and he
insists it's important that everything
his company builds is safe of course
lawmakers want zuckerberg to testify and
could call other witnesses soon tony
yeah a lot of these allegations feel
true to people's experiences on the apps
but facebook is pushing back nicole
thank you very much